here with reaction tonight's big
breaking news author of the upcoming
book it's going to be out June 5th and
available for pre-order now on Barnes
and noble.com Hannity com it's called
Trump's America the truth about our
nation's great comeback former Speaker
of the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich I want to talk about your book
but not now this sorry I like I love you
you're my your family to me but when you
look at this and Ted Olson and Mark Penn
and cheryl atkinson and now even the New
York Times and Washington Post well
trying to get ahead of what they failed
to do for a year and a half and the deep
state is real and the effort to
undermine the president is real FISA
abuse is real spies in the Trump
campaign are real you're the great
historian tell me where this where where
in history this will stack up to well I
think it's rapidly becoming the biggest
and the most sobering political scandal
in American history somebody pointed out
earlier the you know back when J Edgar
Hoover was spying at Lyndon Johnson's
the Heston Richard Nixon we thought it
was terrible back when they had a
break-in at the Watergate we thought it
was terrible this is a multi-year effort
that has two different fronts and people
need to always remember that one front
was protecting propping up covering up
for Bill and Hillary Clinton the other
front whereas Trump became more and more
serious the other front was to stop
Trump at any cost
now I believe that the reason you see
people like Sally Yates go berserk you
see John Brennan go berserk you see
general clapper go berserk
they're all guilty when you see somebody
in the Obama team who gets that rattled
and is that angry what you know is
they're scared to death that they're
going to get drawn into all this and
their role is going to come out and it
will involve I think felonies and
frankly I suspect it reaches to the
President Obama it's inconceivable that
President Obama could have had this many
things going on and not known it because
his administration was very controlling
and very tight and I think we're gonna
discover all this stuff in the end ends
up at the Obama White House and has the
president and his senior staffs
fingerprints all over it question
remains what did he know what did Carrie
know what did Susan Rice and Ben Rhodes
know what did clapper and Brendon know
we haven't even talked about on masking
but you're right Hillary gets a rigged
investigation and then comes the effort
to undermine a president or candidate
than a president-elect and then a
president in the United States and you
put spies and you like or you lie to
FISA judges I think I think the number
one thing the average everyday American
can take from all this is that the
corruption was so deep at the top and
again remember we're not talking about
the everyday FBI agent doing their job
we're talking about people at the very
top and those people were so corrupt and
so arrogant that they thought they could
get away with anything and so they just
proceeded down the road
protecting Hillary covering up Hillary
giving them unity to people who are
breaking the law and then going after
Trump and going after Trump supporters
the when all of this comes out as one in
a way that's easy to understand which
may take frankly another year or a year
and a half because there's so much of it
and every time we turn around as you
know another piece unravels and and
you've had more big stories in the last
year and a half that I would have
thought possible and again and again
you've been right and inch-by-inch even
the New York Times are sailing to
concede and I think by the way mark
Penn's column today there's a real
breakthrough we have a genuine
unqualified member of the left saying
this is a threat to all of us and we
have got to get rid of Miller because he
literally threatens every American's
freedom mr. speaker you understand the
Constitution you understand
checks and balances separation of powers
constitutional authority
oversight of Congress how dare rod
Rosenstein who already is conflicted in
this by recommending the firing of Comey
and signing one of the FISA warrants how
dare they not turn this over to Congress
but that's what they have done
what should Congress do your former
speaker well I mean first of all I think
it's beginning to move in the right
direction I think the president is
beginning to weigh in to reinforce the
Republicans in Congress I think you know
general Kelley being given this
assignment is a very tough very serious
man and I think he is going to impose on
the Justice Department doing their job
of turning over legitimate appropriate
information to the legislative branch
but everybody ought to remember you
mentioned the Constitution remember that
when they were done writing it Benjamin
Franklin was asked by a woman you know
what have we got and he said we have a
republic if we can keep it this is one
of those great tests in American history
corruption came close to destroying the
liberties you and I believe him and if
Hillary got elected none of this would
have come out scary Mr Speaker we
appreciate your perspective as always